let me let me ask you earlier this week
you called joe biden a trojan horse for
socialism
a puppet of a puppet of left-wing
extremists trying to erase our borders
eliminate our police indoctrinate our
children vilify our heroes and take
away our energy that raises a question
that the median democrats brought up
about ronald reagan in 1984
and john mccain in 2008 that is
do you see joe biden you're the
president in your estimation
i think i look at him from four years
ago he seems frail to me
weak to me i've been very outspoken
about it but
your job is the toughest job for my
position in the world
do you see somebody that has the
strength the stamina the mental
alertness the mental acuity for that job
well you know i don't want to get into
that pretty obvious what's going on i
will say this
when you deal with president xi of china
which i do all the time and with
president putin and with uh president
erdogan
and you're dealing with all of these
people kim jong-un
of course obama never spoke to him i
said did he ever speak to him before
going to war he said no i never spoke to
him
so you know you're dealing with these
people i can tell you one thing they're
very sharp but they're at the top of
their game
and if you're not at the top of your
game it's not going to be a pretty
picture it's like
chess masters and if you're not a great
chess master you're going to have a
problem
and that we don't think he is so i don't
know you know one thing you
you left off your list though is he
wants to take away they will take away
without question your second amendment
that's like
without question i've been fighting that
now successfully very successfully it's
not going anywhere with
me here and we have some good people
kevin mccarthy's
great and uh we've we really have some
great people
fighting for us but the second amendment
is gone you could forget about the
second amendment if we lose this
election and your taxes will be doubled
tripled and quadrupled your jobs will be
gone
i mean you're gonna have a depression if
that happens
and it's the biggest headwind you know
we just sat a new record on the stock
market
and believe it or not the biggest
headwind it would have been much higher
but the biggest headwind and that's
during the pandemic
which i hope is nearing the final turn
but the biggest single headwind is if he
got in
if if they didn't think if we win just
like last time we wanted it went up like
a rocket ship
right after the election the same thing
would happen now so those 401ks will go
up 25
30 40 but they will go down 40 or 50
percent
if he gets in all the stuff that you're
talking about is going to kill our
country and kill the economy
housing starts the i honestly from my
perspective
i didn't think after the the shutdown
that jobs would come back as quickly as
they came
back i was surprised when we got the
main numbers and then the june numbers
uh but housing starts consumer
confidence
all the indications what what are you
seeing for this third quarter
i think we're gonna have a great third
quarter a great fourth quarter but we're
going to have an incredible next year
and you look at you know you're talking
about the employment numbers and
you look at the numbers that just came
in for the quarter and they're
record-setting over nine million jobs
and that's really with a minimum of
stimulus because as you know the
democrats don't want to approve stimulus
for people all they want to do is get
bailout money for their governors that
have done so badly in
states like new york and illinois he's
done a terrible job in illinois pritzker
terrible he doesn't know what he's doing
and
you know they're having a hard time in
california as you know although he's
treated me very nicely therefore i'm
going to treat him very nicely but
uh you know they're having a hard time
but they want
bailout money in and other democrat-run
states also
republicans are doing very well
republican states are doing great you
look at what's happening they're doing
great but
these democrats and this is long-term
this isn't just over the last
few years this is for many many years
and they want to they think they can use
the
kovid or they could use the china plague
as we call it
to get bailout money and you know we
don't want to do that
obama said you last night you you've
shown no interest in putting in the work
and
he's been acting like you know remember
they go low we go
high and all that stuff i didn't see
particular the the high
uh in his speech or michelle obama's
speech
your reaction to both of their speeches
and uh one thing you said that
interested me is you believe that they
paved the way for you to be
elected no without them i would nev
not you know when i talk about them i'm
talking about without biden and obama i
wouldn't be president i wouldn't have
run they were so bad and people don't
remember the
hatred and division there was tremendous
division probably a little more quiet
but it was tremendous hatred and
division that
we had for eight years and
you know people don't like to talk about
that but you remember it well he was a
terrible president
he was a very divisive person a very
divisive president
we had the slowest recovery in the
history of our countries
from from 1929 let's say i guess
they say from 1929 the great depression
this was the slowest recovery
we've ever had under him and then when i
got in it was a rocket ship
we gained and now incredibly the stock
market is
i mean nasdaq is actually higher than it
was
at any time and the rest of it looks
like it's going to be higher just almost
the same and
who would have thought that's possible
this is while we're going through this
problem caused by china
you know let me let me ask you you said
about
the election the only way they could win
is a rigged election
this whole issue of mail-in in balloting
the heritage foundation i have it here
in front of me they did sampling of
election fraud cases across the country
what they found is 1088
proven instances of voter fraud and that
includes
949 criminal convictions
they had a philadelphia fraud case that
has expanded
a west virginia mail carrier nabbed in a
mail-in ballot scheme california voter
fraud
exposed what they called a skid row
scheme
illinois let non-citizens register to
to vote in a blunder there alabama
absentee
uh ballot fraud in 2019 a paid a
vote scheme uh exposed in new jersey a
wisconsin county supervisor admitted to
ballot fraud
absentee ballot theft in florida the
wife of a mayoral candidate nabbed in
new mexico
indiana cop convicted of voter fraud to
help his father win the race double
voting in arizona
1088 proven cases of voter fraud 949
criminal conviction sir well it's a
disaster and it's going to be no matter
how you look at it they're sending out
51 million ballots to people that didn't
ask for them
now absentee ballots are great i used
one for florida
and a lot of people use absentee a lot
of people in florida use them
but that's when you go through a process
you ask for it they
send it to you and it's very secure
there's nothing like going to the
voters booth by the way but it's very
and we should have voter id which the
democrats don't want for obvious reasons
with your picture on it but absentee is
good
but they want to send it's called
mail-in universal mail-in
ballots 51 million ballots
sent to who knows who
i mean you know where are they going
this is going to be the greatest scam in
history
this will be the most fraudulent
election in history
51 million ballots being sent to people
many of them will have been dead
many of them will get more than one but
it's going to be a
really horrible thing just a horrible
horrible thing
and it's impossible to police yet
carolyn maloney a congresswoman is not a
very good one
on the east side of manhattan i mean
that thing was so messed up for weeks
and weeks and they just declared her a
winner but they have no idea where the
votes are where the ballots are
it's gone new jersey a disaster it's
been a disaster in new jersey a
horrible disaster and virginia's been
and we're talking about things that just
took place
and small elections relatively but now
they're talking about sending 51 million
ballots out
to anybody that you know nobody knows
who's going to get them
it's a horrible thing it's a fraudulent
election
everybody knows it you don't even have
to know politics to know it
51 million ballots are going to be
indiscriminately sent out
to people that didn't even ask for them
people are going to say hey i just got a
ballot that's great let me vote
and it's uh it's a terrible thing
they're trying to steal the election
dr fauci said it would be safe with
social distancing
and mass for for people to vote in
person
uh this is the dnc convention week well
i've been on fox now 25 years i always
go to the the dnc and the rnc
conventions
if i was at the dnc convention every
year including
your last election i had to have a a
picture id to get in the building
and i was checked every night as i was
probably double checked but i'm kidding
um to get in the building um
my question to you then is uh
are you going to have poll watchers are
you going to have
an ability to monitor uh to avoid fraud
and
cross-check whether or not these are
registered voters whether or not there's
been identification to know that it's a
real vote from a real american
we're gonna have everything we're gonna
have sheriffs and we're gonna have law
enforcement and we're going to have
hopefully u.s
attorneys and we're going to have
everybody in attorney generals
but it's very hard i mean you have some
of these states sending them out like
nevada
where they don't even have to check the
signatures so anybody can sign it
new jersey just sent it out with the
governor as i understand it just signed
an executive order didn't even go
through the legislature to
get it done and nobody's ever heard of
anything like this
so they're going to be sending out 51
million ballots to people
they have no idea why it's coming who
it's going to
unfortunately they may have a very good
idea the people sending them
they may send them to all democrat areas
not to republican areas
as an example could be the other way too
but i doubt it
so it's a very it's a very serious
problem and you know the other thing a
lot of times you don't even have to send
it back
until after the election so on november
3rd the evening like we're used to
sitting home and hearing
trump won the election what a great
thing and you saw how happy
hillary's people were they were thrilled
when i won you saw that that's a
one of the old times i do remember i got
an emergency call call in the fight
now jonah remember during the debate
when she asked me very strongly well
will you support the decision of the
voters
and i'm looking at her she didn't
support it she still doesn't get it
she's walking around saying
what happened let me well is it true
uh kaylee mcinerney your press secretary
said
that your administration just offered 10
billion dollars
for the u.s postal service uh before the
democrats went on recess
and they turned it down you remember
they there's no trouble with the postal
service postal service is going to do a
good job
you know it's not the postal service
it's what happens to these ballots when
they're sent
who are they being sent to who are these
51 million ballots
being sent to where are they going who
determines where they're sent to
and you're talking about massive numbers
they couldn't do carolyn maloney who
shouldn't be
able to accept that position by the way
i mean they gave they declared her a
winner over
a guy that's right now looking around
saying what happened
he thought he won uh they just led her a
winner they should do that election over
again in manhattan
it's a disgrace that election but that
was mail-in votes
now that's one small election that was
for a congressional seat in new york
what about you know what what you when
you're sending them all over the country
51 million it's going to be about 51
million they estimate
and they're going to send them to ever
whoever sends those ballots
is a very powerful person and on the
assumption that the person is honest
it's still going to be
fraught with error even if somebody was
going to be honest about it
because people die and then other people
see it and they grab it and they sign it
and they send it back
now you're not going to have you can't
have it it's impossible to have a fair
election like this